taj mais le navigateur solitaire n'a
toujours pas été approuvé sommet
européen à bruxelles
les allemands durcissent le ton et
rappelle à l'ordre les anglais la chine
choisi la france comme partenaire
commercial un important accord signés
notamment dans le secteur nucléaire
saint-etienne une ville traumatisé par
l'échec de manufrance un reportage de
jean marc ingla messieurs bonsoir on a
peut-être localiser alain colas à partir
de maintenant traduisez au conditionnel
tout ce que je vais vous dire un radio
amateur des açores aurait capté un
message dans la nuit ici manureva suis
en difficulté demande l'assistance
message de détresse donc suivi d'une
position très proche de la dmr position
de colas repérer il ya plus de quinze
jours donc le navigateur serait en très
grande difficulté un 2ème radio amateur
celui là américain a confirmé le message
aussitôt bien sûr la marine nationale
qui n'avait pas cessé de sillonner
l'atlantique et qui a été sollicité à
nouveau par le père d'alain colas la
marine donc dépêche un breguet
atlantique
l'avion a décollé en difficulté à 576 km
d à tort dans un appel captée par des
radios amateurs dont la crédibilité a
été établi une voix qui est supposée
être celle d'alain colas a pu dire
numéro 37
manu mérin numéro 37 manureva appel à
l'aide
c'est un échange de conversation n'a pas
pu avoir lieu la marine nationale qui a
déclenché officiellement depuis hier
soir le plan secmar secours maritimes à
la demande de la famille a pris au
sérieux cette information et c'est ainsi
que ce matin un breguet atlantique de
l'aéronavale à décoller des açores pour
survoler la position indiquée par les
radioamateurs 36,2 et 50 web
trente six heures et cinquante nord ce
qui est à fond kilomètres près la
position qu'occupe et en course manureva
quand alain colas a eu à 18 jours son
dernier contact avec radio monte carlo
l'action de la marine nationale procède
par la méthode dite de recherche en car
est croissant ce qui est par étapes a le
moyen d'investigation le plus
caf puisque c'est la méthode
généralement utilisés dans chaque
recherche d'homme à la mer
mais pour l'instant le bréguet
atlantique là toujours ya retrouvé
oui voilà maintenant qu'on me dit que
les fréquences qu'à capter le
radioamateur ne correspondait peut-être
pas aux fréquences du poste de colas on
en est là pour l'instant il est bien
évident que le formidable coup de
projecteur que nous essayons de donner
sur le drame d'un homme seul d'une
vedette ne vont pas nous faire oublier
la quinzaine de concurrents 17 en tout
qui ne sont pas encore arrivés à la
guadeloupe et par mieux surtout les six
qui n'ont pas donné de leurs nouvelles
depuis quelques jours yves le cornec 19
ans va jamal l'épreuve
ils bénéficient d'une dispense sans
nouvelles de lui depuis le 17 novembre
aline marchand à bord d'un monocoque de
11 mètres 50 elle n'a pas signalé sa
position depuis lé 15 9 ans il part en
37 ans aucune nouvelle de lui depuis le
9 9 ans habitués aux compétitions
l'équipage s'est en revanche sa première
course en solitaire son père bar
officier de la marine marchande
il avait prévenu qu'il ne donnerait pas
de ses nouvelles herman brics pas de
signe non plus enfin le sixième jacques
pallas et le moins expérimenté il
navigue depuis trois ans pas donc pour
les concurrents qui ne sont pas encore
arrivés ils sont trés avoir déjà relié
pointe à pitre parmi eux yves ollivaud
le vétéran 68 ans est la première femme
florence arthaud arrivé 11e quatre jours
seulement après les vainqueurs de la
course
c'est une très belle performance
c'est vraiment pour arriver avant oui
j'aurais dit avant je n'avais pas eu de
casse au début j'étais vachement mieux
placé j'en étais dans les quatre
cinquièmes avant les affaires et j'ai
perdu beaucoup de temps et puis j'ai
perdu beaucoup de temps après
à cause d'eux
beaucoup à cause de mon pilote mais ça
tout le monde attend du temps à cause du
pilote
c'est surtout avec la boum enfin disons
que ça change content de travailler se
s'est pas trop mal passé
donc ce que nous pouvions dire ce soir
sur la transatlantique française en
solitaire il est bien évident que des
cars et claude a des nouvelles de colas
il m'interrompt immédiatement deuxième
titre de l'actualité le sommet européen
de bruxelles en fait il s'agit d'un
conseil européen c'est à dire aller
tâche des chefs d'état et de
gouvernement il est présidé par helmut
schmidt et les travaux cet après midi et
demain seront dominées par la relance de
l'europe monétaire
donc il faut bien dire qu'elle est en
quelque peu en veilleuse depuis cinq ans
ce avec la grande-bretagne boude et ses
partenaires avaient plus ou moins que
c'est fait qu'elle soit mise en congé du
système monétaire européen
et cet après midi les allemands ont
durci le ton ils ne sont pas prêts à
accepter que les anglais ne jouent pas
le jeu
actuellement ce billets de 10 francs
français perd chaque année à peu près
10% de sa valeur à cause de l'inflation
dans le même temps ce billet de dix
marques allemand perd environ 3%
seulement ces différences entre les taux
d'inflation explique les variations
entre chaque monnaie et les variations
entre la pouvoir d'achat ce que l'on
discute à bruxelles et bien sûr le moyen
d'empêcher c'est trop grandes variations
entre les monnaies qui gêne
considérablement les échanges
commerciaux et empêche une trop grande
une 30 stabilité des prix de
l'agriculture actuellement on pense que
le nouveau système monétaire européen
s'achemine vers le calcul des valeurs de
chaque monnaie par rapport à une monnaie
de référence
l'écu l'unité monétaire européenne qui
sera en fait un panier des différentes
monnaies à partir de laquelle on
calculera donc les variations les autres
modèles mais surtout les monnaies habib
les pays à monnaie forte devront
intervenir pour empêcher leurs monnaies
de trop moqué ce système imposé à chacun
des devoirs et limitera les initiatives
individuelles de chaque pays les
allemands paieront pour éviter une
réévaluation constant du marc gène dans
exportations la france et des autres
pays devront observer une grande
discipline en matière de prix de salaire
de dépenses budgétaires
tous les gouvernements seront donc
la concertation et discussions de
bruxelles sont donc autant politique que
technique participer ou non au système
monétaire européen est en effet un choix
politique et la question se pose
aujourd'hui pour la grande bretagne
monsieur queyranne va-t-il oui ou non
faire entrer son pays dans le système et
si oui comment
telle est aujourd'hui à bruxelles la
question numéro un là deux thèses pour
les allemands pas de demi-mesure
monsieur schmitt l'a dit tout à l'heure
il n'y a pas de statut d'association
possible il faut prendre tous les
risques
si l'on veut les avantages monsieur
giscard d'estaing lui a été beaucoup
plus nuancée il faut faire en sorte at
il dit que la grande bretagne puisse
entrer dans le système le moment venu
autrement dit le bâton ou la carte à
partir de là il reste aux experts et aux
diplomates à trouver une formule quasi
magique pour maintenir la grande
bretagne dans la famille européenne
on en reparlera ce soir au coin du feu
il est vraisemblable que valéry giscard
d'estaing durant tout tout ce conseil
européen recevra un ou deux appels de
pékin à l'autre bout du fil son ministre
du commerce extérieur jean françois
deniau qui vient de signer un accord de
très grande importance avec les chinois
un accord à long terme dans lequel on
retrouve pêle-mêle l'aéronautique la
sidérurgie les transports l'électronique
et le pétrole et l'équipement hôtelier
au bout du compte c'est à dire dans sept
ans les échanges en caux chinois
atteindrait vous le voyez ainsi 60
milliards de francs ce qui est énorme
quand on le compare à la situation
d'aujourd'hui
enfin il est vraisemblable que la chine
achètera la france deux réacteurs
nucléaires
ce qui donnera un nouveau souffle un
secteur qui aurait bien besoin de cette
pente
voici la première usine nucléaire en
état de marche que la france a vendu à
l'étranger
lusine de tokaï mura au japon il s'agit
de ce que l'on appelle un centre de
retraitement du combustible atomique
usées mal employer cette usine peut
permettre de fabriquer directement de
l'explosif nucléaire vous comprendrez
que les accords de vente franco-japonais
comportait de nombreuses garanties et
des surveillances de l'utilisation
un tel accord n'a pas pu être obtenue
avec la corée du sud
de même entre le pakistan et la france
la vente a buté sur la sécurité
par contre les centrales atomiques qui
ne produisent que de l'électricité et
des déchets qui retourne en france sont
un peu plus facile à vendre
ce modèle actuellement en construction
en france a déjà été placé en iran et en
afrique du sud
il s'agit de centrales nucléaires
d'origine américaine mais que la france
peut commercialiser sous son nom avec
ces industriels sans retraitement des
déchets l'état possible de fabriquer des
explosifs nucléaires avec de telles
installations
et ce sont deux telle centrale que notre
pays négocierait actuellement avec la
chine les etats unis ont donné leur feu
vert la semaine dernière est paraît-il à
mettre au point les détails de la vente
mais l'accord de ce matin ne mentionne
nulle part une quelconque centrales
nucléaires mais plutôt des centrales
hydrauliques la pétrochimie la
sidérurgie et même des fusées le reste
de l'actualité à l'étranger maintenant
avec la libération de l'ex nazi
néerlandais peter benton la suite des
événements sanglants d'iran mais d'abord
des nouvelles de la santé du président
boumédiène les institutions algériennes
seront respectés la ligne politique
suivie depuis 1965 sera maintenu cette
déclaration du conseil de la révolution
faite hier soir à alger est l'une des
rares manifestations publiques
traduisant politiquement la gravité du
mal dont souffre le chef de l'état un
appareil de détecteur de bulles sanguine
vient en outre d'être expédiés de
marseille au chevet nous suivront a dit
m
plusieurs milliers de manifestants
aujourd'hui encore à téhéran la police
est intervenue pour les disperser
ce matin un attentat contre un bâtiment
de la police a fait un mort et plusieurs
blessés
en france un représentant du ministère
des affaires étrangères a rappelé cet
après midi à l'ayatollah comme unis qui
poursuit ses appels de la désertion aux
soldats iraniens l'obligation de réserve
qui s'impose à tous ressortissants
étrangers se trouvant en territoire
français
condamné à 15 ans de prison en 1977 pour
crimes de guerre commis en pologne
twitter une classe maintain remis en
liberté un tribunal de la haye a estimé
qu'une poursuite après une si longue
période est en principe contraire à une
bonne procédure et à l'accord européen
sur les droits de plus au cambodge il se
confirme bien que l'opposition khmer est
en train de s'organiser elle a constitué
un fonds de salut national ces radios
hanoi qu'il a annoncé mais on peut
considérer l'information comme solides
fait que ce soir le vietnam sera l'un
des sujets de notre magazine question de
temps avec un portage de jacques à
bouchard sur les réfugiés et une
inteview de l'ambassadeur du vietnam à
paris magazine au cours duquel nous
essaierons aussi de prendre la tension
des droits de l'homme un peu partout
dans le monde
l'un des endroits où ils sont le plus
bafoués et bien évidemment l'afrique du
sud et vous pourrez suivre la une
enquête de patrick clément mais en
prélude à cette enquête
écoutez bien le témoignage qui va suivre
il est vraiment glaçant c'est l'histoire
de monsieur et madame de proches qui
habitent le cas lui est d'origine belge
elle est mulâtre voilà 28 ans qu'elle
vit avec lui mais ils ne sont pas mariés
ils ont eu cinq enfants
d'après la loi ils n'ont pas le droit
d'avoir des relations sexuelles
ils ont donc vécu dans l'angoissé
quotidienne d'être arrêté et séparé
leurs enfants des mulâtres ont
aujourd'hui été reclassifiées blanc le
drame devait arriver
votre petite mine voyous qu'est ce que
cela signifie pour vous d'être classifié
mulâtre cela signifie que selon la loi
je ne devrais pas vivre avec les blancs
je devrai dans une place réservée aux
gens de couleur totalement éloigné de ma
famille
ils veulent sans doute que je me suicide
pour être hors du chemin mais que puis
je dire d'autre donc madame ça signifie
que en tant que mulâtre vous n'êtes pas
autorisé à aller avec votre marié vos
enfants dans un restaurant dans un
cinéma etc
c'est exactement cela je me sens dégradé
vous voyez je trouve qu'ils sont
injustes
comment puis-je être une chose et mes
enfants une autre comment une mère
peut-elle être mulâtres et ses enfants
pleins retrouve terrible la manière dont
les choses se passent ici je n'ai aucun
droit sur mes enfants et quand les
enfants se marieront je devrais rester
dans le france
à l'arrière c'est terrible si les
enfants de monsieur madame de profs
considéré comme mulâtre ont été
aujourd'hui reclassifier blanc ce n'est
pas l'effet du hasard
cette mesure exceptionnelle en afrique
du sud est intervenue après un drame
atroce qui a endeuillé cette famille
victime comme des milliers d'autres des
lois absurdes de l'apartheid
leur fils aîné robert classifiés mulâtre
âgé de 19 ans s'est suicidé quand il
apprit qu'il ne pourrait pas épouser sa
jeune fiancée blanche qui était enceinte
il est entré à la maison est alors dans
la soirée il est monté à la gare et mes
deux aînés le garçon et la fille ont
couru derrière
pour lui parler mais il ne leur a pas
dit qu'il allait se jeter sous un train
ils parlaient ensemble entre eux quand
soudain très arrivée il s'est précipité
en face du train et il a été tué
pourquoi
c'est à cause des lois is love chloé loi
on y défend des d'épouser la fille qui
attendait un enfant de lui
nous sommes fiancés des cancers et ils
ne savaient pas quoi faire attendez que
nous l'aidions mais nous étions dans la
même position et on ne savions pas nous
mêmes
comment l'aider et lui dire ce qu'il
fallait faire parce qu'il était
considéré comme un mulâtre
c'est ça oui ces choses
le tourmentait c'est devenu
insupportable pour lui d'une cote match
et il a fait ce qu'il a fait il dit
droite
oui c'est un reportage de la rtb qui
sera donc diffusée dans question de
temps à 21h30 dans ce magazine consacré
aux droits de l'homme l'actualité
politique en france maintenant tourne
beaucoup autour des élections
européennes d'abord ce sondage sofres
sud-ouest 51% des français contre 43 ne
souhaite pas que l'assemblée européenne
accroisse ses pouvoirs au détriment des
gouverneurs ensuite la non une
plateforme libérale du centre national
et d'indépendance et ce qu'elle dit
bertrand motte à sa sortie de l'hôtel
matignon
ensuite la fin est plutôt la suite de la
polémique entre l'udf et le rpr à propos
du rejet du projet de la tva européenne
à l'assemblée la semaine dernière c'est
un coup bas estime la lettre de l'idf
qui espère que ses partenaires n'irons
pas plus loin que le mauvais coup c'est
une déclaration qui n'est pas dans le
ton habituel des dirigeants du df les
paysans du larzac satisfaction mais
vigilance c'est ce qui ressort de
l'entrevue d'hier matin une dizaine de
marcheurs et le directeur de cabinet du
ministère de la défense
pourtant les paysans qui ont les pieds
sur terre si je puis dire attendent
maintenant des résultats pratiques une
porte s'est ouverte distille reste à
savoir ce qu'il ya derrière ce pourrait
bien être des oubliettes ou des
chausse-trappes
on va aller assez vite à que le match
nous allons fixer les rendez vous
d'ici la fin de l'année médiane et vous
les ultimatums n'envie pas longtemps et
75 aussi les ultimatums on ça fait deux
années sans tomber nous sommes encore su
plateau et je pense que le principal
pour nous c'est de rester sur un plateau
et nous allons prendre des toutes les
possibilités qui seront à pouvoir de
pouvoir rester sur le plateau puisque
dans l'art et culture savait très bien
que la rupture vis avec de crédit avec
des primes
tout ça ça risque d'être supprimée il
faut alors qu'on prenne des mesures pour
continuer à vivre sur le larzac est donc
la seule action dont nous pouvons dire
actuellement si nous sommes créé une
banque une bonne mutuelle pour qu'elle
puisse se substituer au crédit aricole
si le crédit agricole est défaillant
c'est la seule action vos nouveaux nous
allons faire actuelle les malheurs de
d'abia d'abyei est une jeune femme de 24
ans vient qu'algérienne elle est née en
france de parents algériens et la couler
des jours heureux jusqu'en avril dernier
date à laquelle elle perdit ses papiers
mais on veut aujourd'hui l'expulser car
elle n'a jamais demandé la nationalité
française
dahbia sera donc refoulés en algérie à
la fin de cette année détective cette
tête de ma mère aux ouvertures
croustillantes aguichante interdit à
l'affichage et à la vente aux mineurs
christian bonnet le ministre l'intérieur
a accepté la proposition de la
commission de surveillance des
publications destinées aux moins de 18
ans l'éditeur lui estime qu'il a été
condamné à mort les affaires sociales
maintenant avec au delà des déclarations
patronale politiques ou syndicales la
crise de manufrance cette crise quittent
aussi le drame d'une ville déjà
largement touchée par le chômage
un reportage de jean marc il use et de
michel a dit qu il y a des villes dont
les murs parlent à saint-etienne ils
parlent de chiffres
manufrance 4000 emplois en 1974 2006 ans
aujourd'hui dont 13 cents peut être déjà
condamné un compte à rebours
interminable une menace qui se précise
dernier espoir nouveau combat au bar de
lusine c'est tout le climat qui a changé
si vous voulez avant c'était on avait la
clé celle de société le café en face
était plat quoi c'était alors le monde
qui qui passait aux sorties à deux
heures à midi c'est incroyable ce
courriel l'ambiance en fait tu manques
il y avait peut-être que maintenant si
ces morts causé
mais je note quand même confiance mais
je pense que ça ça doit pas tomber à
saint-etienne un phare mais bon il le
faut parce que ça dégage une devant ce
que ça se manifeste par un bar
plan de sauvetage restructuration
règlement de compte politique
dans cette ville où chacun accuse
personne n'échappe à l'inquiétude
comme ce commerçant du quartier beaulieu
40% de ses clients travaillent chez manu
france et quand il ya eu du chômage
technique
j'ai eu l'impression enfin j'ai ressenti
d'après les recettes journalières que ça
va baisser assez conséquent d'encre ce
qui fait que maintenant j'ai craint
aussi pour la suite
une petite entreprise de moins de 10
personnes comme il y en a des centaines
dans la région 80 % du chiffre
d'affaires c'est manu france il ne sera
pas facile de trouver d'autres débouchés
vu la conjoncture actuelle est ce qu'on
pourra essayer de ceux de se recycler si
manufrance fermer ses portes
on pourrait peut-être vend des tables de
ping pong autres camani france mais est
ce qu'avec les transports on pourrait
arriver à soutenir la concurrence
on espérait partir en zone industrielle
et faire construire une ligne beaucoup
plus moderne et faire davantage de table
et peut-être descendre le prix de
revient
les projets de monsieur chaîne va
resteront peut-être sur papier
manufrance lui doit 360 mille francs à
peine le millième de la dette totale de
la plus vieille entreprise de
saint-etienne pour réduire cet
endettement affirme maintenant la
direction il faudrait licencier 1300
personnes
tous les jours on se demande qu'est ce
qu'on va ainsi les portes
mon paternel comme des cantons partir
travailler le matin les sapeurs et pour
trouver du travail après c'est quand il
y en a qui sont pas jeunes pousses de 48
ans - 48 ans finit sera plus troy
il avait joué entre le point ils rendent
28 ans de boîte
et ça me fait mal au coeur de voir
disparaître il en tombe sous le sens ya
un truc que je comprends pas c'est que
d'un jour l'autre on avait du travail
et puis après il ya plein pourquoi en
cette fin d'année on compte des jeux à
saint-etienne une dizaine de milliers de
son travail
autres points noirs dans l'horizon
social le creusot loire aux 600 700 même
licenciements déjà annoncés s'ajoutant
prévisions près de 400 autres
en tout plus de 11 cents donc autres
industries en difficulté celle du
téléphone le groupe c it et alcatel est
le premier des grands fabricants a
décidé une reproduction d'une réduction
pardon d'effectifs 920 en 79 cela touche
essentiellement les régions du nord de
la rochelle et de la bretagne
les évêques en guerre contre l'alcool
réunie aujourd'hui à paris de la
commission sociale de l'épiscopat cela
fait trois ans qu'elle enquête sur
l'alcoolisme et qui accumule des
témoignages sur ce dossier cette
commission qui n'a pas froid aux yeux
lance un cri d'alarmé et tout en
proposant un seul homme d'action elle
accuse elle accuse la société vous avez
pu entendre monseigneur boye ans
l'évêque de verdun dans l'émission c'est
la vie et 18h35 proposition d'abrogation
de la loi marthe richard marthe richard
c'est savait qu'ils avaient fait fermer
les maisons closes en 46 j'ai dépanné
mais on m'a dit ces jeunes le tac qui
l'a déposé ce matin à l'assemblée
nationale pour le député rpr il ne
s'agit pas de rouvrir les maisons closes
mais du vrai que la prostitution soit
autorisée et réglementée en tout cas par
les maires avec un contrôle médical à la
clôture dès aujourd'hui des six grands
prix littéraire de la saison avec la
terreur
et l'interallié un jury de journalistes
pour un journaliste c'est la couture et
cette année il est allé à jean-didier
wolfrum wolfrum enfin serais je tenté de
dire je vous avais prévu déjà depuis de
lundi vous n'avez pas eu le renaudot pas
eu le goncourt et le médicis pas eu le
femina c'est un prix de raccroc un petit
peu l'interallié
ça a pris de caussade assure si j'avais
été triste mais je ne sais pas trop vous
avez été longtemps le critique
littéraire à françois roux nouvellement
pereire critiques féroces tignes même
dit souvent vos confrères
et là ils ont été très gentils avec vous
c'est la complaisance ou sinon genre de
jouet pense pas je crois que ces deux
métiers différents pains critique
regarde à l'ifsi je me trouvais bon tant
mieux pour moi il ya aussi une chose que
je voudrais dire c'est que je ne crois
vraiment pas que ce soit moins qu'ils
soient durs c'est la critique qui s'est
radouci suffit de lire les critiques du
début du siècle et léon daudet et plein
de gens extrêmement violent avec
quelquefois des académiciens maintenant
les plusieurs lauréats que les
académiciens et rapporter la vérité vous
vous êtes dur avec beaucoup frais mais
vous êtes dur avec vous même ou si vous
vous et allez dans ce livre sans
complaisance on peut considérer que le
personnage central c'est vous non on ne
peut pas le considérer parce que d'abord
je vous rends bien alou je ne suis pas à
nos 10 capes effigie or le pas de calais
racontée par un handicapé physique j'ai
pas de cannes j'ai j'ai pas tous les
problèmes qu'a eu thierry disons
simplement j'ai peut-être rencontrer
diane losfelt alors j'ai éprouvé l'amour
ça m'a frôlé mais ça ma patte
j'ai donc vraiment un roman vous avez
des problèmes physiques que vous
dépeignez un petit peu quand même dans
votre livre vous donnez l'impression de
régler un compte avec vous même non mais
vous savez les problèmes physiques jésus
mais c'est par intuition que j'ai
ressenti ce que pouvaient ressentir
quelqu'un qui était plus un handicap et
moi et c'est là que le roman il ya
quelque chose de passionnant parce que
raconter ma vie ça ne présente aucun
intérêt
celle de thierry est un film en plus
intéressant il admire et malgré cette
quête assez difficile de l'amour d'une
femme
vous n'avez pas l'air de d'éprouver une
la moinde misogynie pas dans votre
libraire ge dans les femmes et je pense
que dans ce cas précis diane nanterre à
idées thierry est en tous les cas il à l
a aidé au truc à marcher et même à le
faire marcher un peu plus loin elle l'a
fait passer de l'âge de pitié comédie à
l'âge d'homme dans tous les cas l ajd
amoureux et c'est une grande nouvelle
pour lui simplement il n'a peut-être pas
su la prendre dans tous les sens du
terme et en tous les cas elle a mon avis
ne l'aimé pas donc diane ans terre
jean-didier wolfrum jeu chez grasset la
page de la météo pour terminer je suis
aujourd'hui redoux et pluie demain
moitié ouest un temps très nuageux sur
le reste de la france et brumes et
brouillards matinaux qui se dissiperont
vous ne voyez pour donner un temps
nuageux avec quelques éclaircies
rappel des rendez-vous d'information ce
soir sur un thème de 21h30 question de
temps un magazine présenté par louis
blériot avec donc outre l'apartheid
outre le problème du vietnam des
reportages sur les argentins et sur les
dissidents tchécoslovaques rechute
réfugie en france presse un magazine sur
les droits de l'homme aujourd'hui en 78
et puis vers 23h10 le dernier journal
qui vous sera présenté ce soir par hervé
claude j'en profite tout de suite aussi
pour vous dire que tout à l'heure les
téléspectateurs de la région parisienne
ont connu une panne de secteur une fois
nos secteurs donc qui a duré à peu près
dix minutes je vous prie de nous en
excuser
et puis pour terminer tout à fait ce
journal des images qui je pense feront
plaisir aux belles et oman-- et aux
autres le grand rival du bolchoï de
moscou et à paris s'agit du ballet kirov
de linde rade au programme des ballet
romantique giselle lac des cygnes
et puis une oeuvre contemporaine notre
dame de paris sur une musique de
montrichard arrivé hier le ballet kirov
répétait déjà ce matin et joue ce soir
au palais des volets la troupe de ballet
de leningrad autrefois saint pétersbourg
son célèbre depuis le xviiie siècle
tous les grands ballets romantiques de
la belle au bois dormant aussi
ils y ont été créés parmi les plus
célèbres danseurs sortie du ballet kirov
site en lysine ski noureev et plus
récemment baryshnikov je pense que la
réputation du kirov n'est pas usurpée la
technique de ce ballet est irréprochable
dans le classique le soin le travail et
le talent des interprètes placé
aujourd'hui sous la direction d'oleg
vinogradov classe cette troupe au sommet
du gotha artistes un spectacle à ne pas
manquer d'autant plus que le ballet
kirov n'est pas venu en france depuis 13
ans
allah
voilà bonsoir à tous à demain